I never understood exercise for Real uh
until
Valerie said something and it's on a
Post-It above my Tre my treadmill
brag
but there's a posted and it says Let the
Body solve what the mind can't and I was
like oh my [ __ ] this is like another way
of saying Let Your Heart Take the reins
and say yes thank you that's like a way
of just going a let the body solve what
the mind can't meaning there are some
problems in your life
that you your brain is like just let me
keep replaying it I'll just keep this on
a loop
how's all night sound
can you do all night
looking at your calendar there's nothing
but me and you and darkness
so it thinks it's doing something it
actually thinks it's helping by worrying
and I would do that and then when I
realize that there's just look there's a
humbling experience when you realize you
basically you are a block of tofu and
the thing that flavors you are your
hormones you're a chemical creature and
letting the body solve what the mind
can't means do the thing that produces
the hormone that changes the tofu
you know what I mean stop thinking your
way out of the box and you don't have to
have a treadmill go for a walk get in
nature like they say it's 15 minutes in
a green space low just the color green
lowers your blood pressure do breathing
do some uh and you do this you do this
when I'm in a good way there then talk
to me when I'm in a low way maybe I'll
forget because by the way so what this
whole [ __ ] thing is it's a sine wave
it's remembering and forgetting and
remembering and forgetting we just want
to be like an American corporation and
only improve only Skyrocket right those
down times when I would listen to this
podcast and be like I don't know what
the [ __ ] this guy's talking about those
are essential too
foreign